[Music]
[Applause]
warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised oh my God Senator Kennedy has
been shot in the head in June 1968
24-year-old Palestinian refugee Sahan
Sahan shot dead presidential candidate
Bert Kennedy in a hotel
Pantry more than 40 years later he still
claims to have no memory of committing
the act I don't remember I must have
been too hypnotized too much out of my
senses to really be aware of of what
happen it was obvious that he had been
uh programmed to kill Robert Kennedy and
programmed to forget that he' been
programmed we we've seen videos over the
years of um people being able to take
and um groom basically hypnoti using
neural linguistic program there a guy
Nam Darren Brown he wanted to prove that
you could actually take a um an assassin
and cause him to do an assassination
outside of his even knowing about it but
that just shows that there's there's a
wide variety of reasons why you could
cause somebody to go and do that and you
know it's like it was such a strange
thing but I think people need to have
yeah the overarching backing up rather
than getting caught on the details
backing up and going okay where's this
going and what did this cause and as the
people in the world are saying and some
of those in the think tanks are saying
either way a victory for Trump or a
victory for Cala could lead to a civil
[Music]
war hey everybody Welcome to a special
edition of what's up Prof and led live
Blended together I'm excited about this
episode you guys have an awesome
ministry Walter B Martin Smith you guys
are all the way from South Africa and
coming and blessing us every time I see
your stuff it blows my mind I mean I'm
I'm I'm shocked but not shocked and I
think it's awesome that there's Watchmen
on the wall literally bringing to the
Forefront things that are going on in
the in the world making sense of that
and I'm excited to get in this
conversation cuz the world seems like
it's coming apart real quick so welcome
to the show thank you thank what are we
going to talk about today we're going to
talk about current events and how they
dovetail with prophecy all right we know
that according to the Bible there will
be religious legislation MH it it's
called legislating The Mark of the
Beast and we know that that is religious
legislation because it deals with
worship mhm and once it deals with
worship it's dovetailing
with the religious sentiments in the
world and how are these going to come
about in a world that is as secularized
as we have it currently but the Divide
between the secular world and the
religious world seems to be widening and
the conflicts seem to be
increasing and the question is is that
hegelian dialectic to bring about a
certain synthesis a certain
change of sentiment and we want to look
at current events particularly with
regards to the elections in the United
States the assassination attempt on
Donald Trump and what the ramifications
are and how can this play into the
prophetic profile and this is exciting
because for the first time we really can
see a movement in the direction yeah you
see where they're going we see where
they're going and the voices that are
coming up are saying this is what we
need we need to set the record straight
we need to go back to morality we need
to legislate against some of these
things which both sides are calling
weird yes so yeah I mean it's like
they're pushing back the water like this
right and the farther they push the
water back the harder it's going to go
that's it that's exactly where we're
heading so we have our cover picture
here where you have the idea of
ideologies
clashing and the religious World saying
No this is going too far we have to we
have to move in the other direction and
maybe some cataclysmic events that
really Galvanize people mhm can be the
stimulus to do this and we've seen so
many we've seen what happened at the
Olympics and the outcry and the
galvanizing of the Christian world
and the opposition to what's happening
in other religious systems no we are
Christian nations whether this is in
Europe whether it's in England whether
it's in the United States everywhere
we're seeing this movement and so I
believe we're at the pivotal point when
these things can actually start taking
place it's like they're raising the
flags right they're they're getting
ready for the the the March right you
know what's interesting about these two
flags being Blended together that I was
just thinking about both of them are
symbols of Freedom yes but very opposite
ends of the spectrum of freedom I mean
I'm assuming that you know Christianity
is is sort of we should be a Christian
Nation founding fathers principles you
know all these things over here and then
it's like no we want to do whatever we
want to do you know and and that's
what's clashing together I like this
image and also you know the flag on the
right here stands for a republican form
of government m nothing to do with the
Republican Party MH uh whereas the one
on the left stands more for a democratic
system where the majority rules are we
there to defend a constitution or are we
there to bring about majority rule right
if everybody redefines something we sh
move the goalpost just move the goalpost
so there are a lot of ramifications in
this study mhm but one of the
galvanizing factors I believe was the
assassination attempt on Donald Trump
and so many voices from the left said
that it might have been
fake and uh there was a huge outcry and
a backlash so as far as our position is
it's irrelevant whether it was real or
whether it was fake yeah what did it
produce but what is the outcome going to
be and we not here to question the
reality thereof or the unreality thereof
we're only interested in
outcomes and so I think we should launch
into it and see where this is heading
mhh good point so
interesting thing happened in March of
this year there was this
Evangelical um prophets if you can put
it like that that had a discussion and
this one individual actually predicted
very
closely that there will be an ass
assassination attempt on Trump's life
this is three months before the event so
let's listen to this I saw Trump rising
up and then I saw an attempt on his life
uh that this bullet flew by his ear and
it came so close to his head that it
busted his drum eard drum and I saw um
he was he fell to his knees during this
time time frame and he started
worshiping the Lord he got radically
born again during this time frame I'm
talking people say he's saved now but he
becomes really on fire for Jesus for
what I saw coming wait wait this is
three months prior that that what that
video right there yes yes some Minor
Details are not quite right I think it
busted as e drum no but you see it but
this is how the devil works like he
mentioned
we know he's a Christian now and all of
but this will change his life completely
if you want to be involved in true
Christianity it has to be word-based mhm
that was the premise of the Reformation
mhm Thy word that is the basis for all
decision when it comes to emotions and
feelings that is something that's a
paradigm in Christianity today which is
for to what the B actually says so just
a warning out there to everyone we have
to be very very careful that we stay
word-based and not emotion based anybody
can say anything yeah right and that's
what Matthew 7 is all about you go to
that chapter and the people at the end
they're saying you know Lord Lord didn't
we do all these things in your name they
appear to be Christian but he says you
know your profession didn't
match your Works mhm in vain they
worship me yeah teaching for Doctrine
the Commandments of men these are very
important points but the point is here
is a
prediction and you know
before the administration that is
currently ruling in the United States
came into Power the these very same
prophets were very vocal that there
would be a second term for Trump mhm now
it didn't
materialize but they're of course hoping
that it will materialize this time
around and if it does materialize
according to them then they haven't
given false prophets or false prophecies
so whether it happens or not it doesn't
really matter because prophecy will
fulfilled irrespective of whose ruling
yeah in the time of Elijah it was God's
word that stood not the all the prophets
of Baal and their word that was
confusing the people and if this really
is some kind of like setup thing or
whatever and somehow this guy knows this
piece of information right what a great
way to to rewrite the script to to clear
the Slate If people could fault Donald
Trump saying he's a filthy man look what
he's done oh wow he came within an inch
of his life now he's on his knees
praying he's a good guy from here
forward yeah so all of a sudden you're
going to immediately think like who
cares what happened in the past exactly
so whether it is true or whether it is
fake matter matter moving forward it's
what happens what's the outcome and also
this stirred up obviously a lot of
emotion even in the comments of this
video there's people that said I was an
atheist and now after this how can I but
believe you see so this is really
pushing people into a a sympathetic MH
um scenario to maybe listen more to
these type of things like you mentioned
in the beginning mhm Satan is at work
obviously uh demons and they also have
an influence so they this person could
have had a vision you don't know but
it's if it's not it come from yes who
did it come from yeah let's have a look
at the next one and see where where this
is
heading okay so this is where this is
Trump's first speech after the
assassination attemp so many people have
asked me what happened tell us what
happened please and therefore I will
tell you exactly what happened
and you'll never hear it from me a
second time because it's actually too
painful to tell I'm not supposed to be
here tonight not supposed to be here yes
you are yes you are
thank
you but I'm not and I'll tell
you I stand before you in this Arena
only by the grace of almighty
God in watching the reports over the
last few days many people say it was a
providential moment I'm sure that you've
heard a lot of people say this but you
will never be able to convince me that
that last second turn of a head was
anything other than a miracle I
absolutely believe that I watched I
watched the video of what happened in
Butler Pennsylvania about 15 50 times I
think I was one of about 8 billion
people around the world who watched it
and the more I watched it the more it
struck me that everything was different
after that moment everything this
convention is different the nation is
different the world is different Donald
Trump is different when he stood up
after being shot in the face bloodied
and put his hand up I thought at that
moment that was a transformation this
was no longer a
man well I think that I think it was
divine intervention but the effect that
it had on Donald Trump he was no longer
just a political party's nominee or a
former for president or a future
president this was the leader of a
nation and in that moment Donald Trump
months before the presidential election
became the leader of this
nation that was the most obvious to me
and I have to say you know I I I think
it changed him I think a lot of people
are wondering what is this this doesn't
look like politics something bigger is
going on here I think even people who
don't believe in God are beginning to
think well maybe there's something to
this
actually so something very interesting
to me about just words i' I've really
studied words right how is God giving us
the government of God he's using words
here's a book collection and when you
read those words enough times you get
this context of who he is right Devil's
copying that he's going I got some words
for you he's handing you Hollywood right
what he did there psychologically is he
just Blended two words together he's no
longer a man pause M divine intervention
he just linked those two concepts
together right there psychologically in
your mind because you're trying to
follow along and and and those seeds are
going in there that was amazing so what
effect did it have on the Christian
mindset and even those on the edge of
Christianity it galvanized them God is
in control so whether this leads to a
victory or whether it leads to an
apparent failure it still will have
galvanized those and as the people in
the world are saying and some of those
in the think tanks are saying either way
a victory for Trump or a victory for
Kamala could lead to a civil wall oh
yeah cuz if you think this is some
Divine thing and now it's not divinely
playing out because the people are
forcing it yeah you're going to go to
war for that it becomes a religious
battle it becomes a religious
Battlefield it's not no longer just a
political Battlefield wow it's it's a
religious ideology wow and if one side
or the other gains the ascendancy or the
idea againsts ascendancy then religious
legislation can and will be part of the
package deal absolutely for sure for
sure because the other thing is that
you've got the push then of the Olympics
that whole ceremony that's was we'll get
to that in a while but that's the
theatrics part of it that's it if you
put it into prophetic language that was
the King of the South mentality pushing
against this King of the North mentality
mhmh I totally believe that so this is
the United States issue now what if you
could expand that to a worldwide
Christian uh realm philosophy well I've
put in just an interesting Slide the
Assassin or attempted assassin Thomas
krooks this is him here yes this is him
here and people went digging to see
where he could pop up and this is a real
interesting one maybe I won't say much
we can say afterward but something
Thomas Crooks the shooter had appeared
briefly in it filmed in 2022 at bethl
Park High School where he was a senior
at the time but what was the reason for
the commercial the commercial was part
of black Rock's campaign to Showcase its
commitment to education and community
and featured various students from bethl
Park High School among them was Thomas
Crooks who appeared for a fleeting
moment the footage which had been
largely unnoticed until now suddenly
gained immense attention following the
revelation of Crook's involvement in the
assassination attempt as news of Crook's
appearance in the commercial spread
social media has erupted with reactions
many users continue to express shock and
disbelief While others have begun
speculating about potential connections
between books and black rock the
commercial which had been intended to
promote positive Community engagement
was now viewed through a completely
different lens oh we won't make a take a
stand on it it's just something
interesting it's just that people will
be inclined to put this into the
conspiracy theory tank and say that you
know maybe there was something going on
behind the scenes whether or not is
irrelevant yep yep the outcome the
outcome what if even if it was
supernaturally
planned it's still a battle between God
and the forces arrayed against them so
it becomes a religious war or a
religious conflict in the minds of men
mhm and this is where where we're
heading mhm and only when that conflict
bubbles over so that the one tries to
get ascendency over the other then you
have to have legislation in order to do
that me that's what happened when the
Crusades minus the legislation but you
know religious War one idea could
Prevail the other one could not that's
true you know what's interesting about
that that kid is is like
um we we've seen videos over the years
of um people being able to take and um
groom basically hypnotize using neural
linguistic programing there's a guy
named Darren Brown he wanted to prove
that you could actually take a um an
assassin
and cause him to do an assassination
outside of his even knowing about it and
they set this whole stage filmed it up
there and everything like this and then
they videoed him he had this this polka
doted pattern that they had a woman in a
polka doted dress she sat down in front
of him they set up a a fake um um
scenario with a huge audience and when
the woman with the polka doed thing came
out he pulled out a gun and he shot the
guy on stage he's a famous actor that's
on stage and then they you know
everybody's freaking out because nobody
knows about it and and then they brought
the guy back out he came sat down put
the gun back down and just sort of like
went into a sleep mode and then they
said do you know what you just did and
he said no not at all and they said you
don't know anything what you just did
nope not at all and they brought him
into the room and they showed him the
video and the guy just went white as a
ghost like he he was so shocked I did
that they had worked with him for a year
so they had you know manipulated him
over over the course of a year oh my God
Senator keny has been shot in the head
in June 1968 24-year-old Palestinian
refugee Sahan Sahan shot dead
presidential candidate Robert Kennedy in
a hotel
Pantry more than 40 years later he still
claims to have no memory of committing
the act I don't remember I must have
been too hypnotized too much out of my
senses to really be aware of of what
happened it was obvious that he had been
uh programmed to kill Robert Kennedy and
programmed to forget that he been
programmed not allowed to enter the
French language which let's be honest
it's but it's pissing into the wind it
you can't you
can't do you remember that woman in the
polka dot dress no remember turning
around talking to you
no remember that bit
yes at the moment you will have no
memory of this at all but you're just
assassinated a National Treasure yeah
you show
me but that just shows that there's
there's a wide variety of reasons why
you could cause somebody to go and do
that and you know it's like it was such
a strange thing but I think people need
to have yeah the overarching backing up
rather than getting caught on the
details backing up and going okay
where's this going and what did this
cause exactly we always say you have to
be observers yep don't get sucked into
one of the sides yep step back and look
at what's the outcome yep especially
Christianity this is why it's important
where we're meeting a time that we need
to understand prophecy you know it's
really great to see where is this thing
headed to in Revelation and how did that
tie back to what the elements of Daniel
were dealing with and you know we're
seeing the outcome of that play out
today and if you if you con consider
that there is a battle behind the scenes
a conflict between Christ and Satan then
there must be two sides pulling strings
the one is allowed to coers and the
other one never coerces the one is
allowed to do things in secret the other
one is never do to do anything in secret
so these are are powers that are playing
behind the scenes and hypnosis is always
part of the plan I mean if you take uh
uh the Third Reich mhm those speeches
they had hypnotic effects on the
populace mhm and many were sloon along
MH and that that is a form of coercion
so it could be totally subconscious for
even the role players but the one
pulling the strings the Demonic forces
behind the scenes can manipulate and use
those that Third Reich I'm sure was an
emotionally charged situation yeah they
know how to manipulate the masses I mean
you go back read you know watch what
Edward bernes came up with with you know
applying Sigman Freud's things to the
masses and like we know that this
technology exists so you know we're at
the end yes M and you know under
hypnosis people uh can do things that
they will they cannot possibly remember
what happened mhm and there is a form of
total
control and it's interesting that the
spirit of Prophecy warns against
hypnosis but the medical world often
Embraces it mhm mhm very true you see
and this next slide actually fits in
very nicely to all of that because I
don't know if many people know in the
some years back how influential Donald
Trump was in the wrestling scene that
WWE you mentioned that before we started
I was shocked by that I was like what he
was a wrestler
well he wasn't a wrestler but he was in
very influential in the you'll see now
in the video as well but what I just
realized is I don't maybe in the US many
people know but I don't think many
people outside of the US even knows this
yeah but look at look a WWE maybe will
come to a shock to people that's
Entertainment that's also like Hollywood
style that's actually cheesy
entertainment it's not real yeah cheesy
entertainment and you know and and you
have to be a good actor yeah you have to
be a very good actor and how much
influence on the crowd do they put out
there it's all about hyping up the crowd
that's really what it's about so it
doesn't that make him then excellent at
hyping up crowds that's a really good
point in when he goes to a rally look at
the similarity when you see this video
let me just tell you a couple of things
Vince number one this is peanuts I paid
a big price for raw you know that a big
price did I big I can do whatever the
hell I want about the only thing I can
say to you here tonight is Donald Trump
yeah let me put it very simply
Vince I'm taller than
you I'm better looking than
you I think I think I'm stronger than
you
wow
and I'm here to challenge you to a match
in WrestleMania Stone Co Steve Austin
what's going on over here Donald Trump
is in a world he is not familiar with
this is not real
estate this is the WWE Donald Trump may
have to get his hands dirty
himself may have to throw set and get
involved here hey look at this Donald
Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump taking
oh my God the Hostile takeover of Donald
Trump on this McMahon has happened at
Wrestlemania 23 I didn't think he
was a restraining McMan is's begging
don't do this to for a reprieve and is
saying oh no
they're both the same actors I mean they
like look the same Vince McMahon and and
you see so that it's just amazing to me
the way that he let's say gets the
crowds riled up at his rallies yeah
isn't much different than no it's
not that's a very interesting piece of
evidence what does an assassination
attempt do to the minds of people that
are sitting on the fence or people that
are already decided doesn't it cement
them in a particular mindset I think you
look rather cruel if you then talking
smack about somebody that just almost
lost their life correct you know so what
happened to Ronald Dragon when he
survived assassination attempt let's
just go back in history while he
survived an assassination attempt and
his response changed the trajectory of
his
presidency so what transpired over the
next few hours became the stuff of
presidential and political Legend
Reagan's courage over those tense hours
further cemented his relationship and
political standing with the American
public and the same thing is happening
here with Donald Trump it he's cementing
his standing and his courage is
something that even his enemies have
mentioned and has turned some of them
around from being antitrump to Pro prot
Trump so whether this is planned or
whether this is circumstantial and just
happens is irrelevant the fact of the
matter is it's happening so an
assassination attempt in Brazil brought
politics into
churches so now you're mixing was that
this year no this article is from this
year this happened in
2007 18 before the election yeah all
right they're the presidential candidate
bonaro was stabbed a month before the
2018 election and what did that bring
about though bonaro didn't exit the
attack on his life with the fist pump
and look of defiance his recovery from
the assassination attempt nevertheless
energized his base and grew his
supporters including among significant
members of the Evangelical Christians
who would Propel him to the presidency a
couple of months later so does it have
an effect on the mindset and does
Christianity or does the church often
get involved and say that it's divine
intervention and therefore choose a
particular path isn't it interesting
that you see sometimes often things
prior to um what happens in the United
States maybe almost like testing the
waters how does this outcome happen or
are we learning from how this happened
and then going hey that's a good idea I
mean the last president that was there
was an assassination attempt on was
Reagan mhm and if you can parallel some
of the events there he was shot and then
there's a lot of parallels that Happ an
actor
Republican nobody remembers him um
except fondly you know people think back
Reagan is a good guy he was a good
president you know people just they're
making a movie about him now it's going
to be released soon I think it's Dennis
Quaid or somebody playing him so kind of
interesting how nobody people think of
Kennedy nobody remembers him like Oh
Kennedy was a bad guy no it's like
President Ken he's a good guy you know
he got shot Lincoln oh yeah he was a
good president good guy and they all
sure probably had their own
personal problems right all their
defects of character and what's
interesting is when something like that
takes place in the United States of
America that sentiment spills over to
the rest of the world it does in the
time of Reagan you had thatcherism in
the United Kingdom and you had a
conservative wave moving we have we have
a similar thing happening now the world
is not in the conservative wave it's in
the liberal wave but there are all of
these sentiments that are pushing it
into that conservative wave worldwide
you're also seeing in the entertainment
Spectrum um different actors that you
would have thought never are identifying
as Christian like you know what was the
guy that would that was always doing the
um Alice Cooper and people like that
that you're just like you you were
working for Satan and Russell Brand for
brand Brad Pit you name them they're all
just oh yeah I'm Christian too it's
interesting like they're putting the
vision out there for people like oh yeah
follow this but there there's no
specific Doctrine attached to it it's
just a statement mhm and it's it Chumps
the denominational divide many of them
are turning to Catholicism others to
evangelicalism and uh Donald Trump
himself is married to a very devout
Roman Catholic lady so you have this mix
of religions constantly in the Forefront
it's an
ecumenical religion we're all one a
Christianity has to stand together and
then there's the outside enemy the one
that wants to convert the world to Islam
and that's what's happening in the
United Kingdom now for example where
you're saying all right enough is enough
and you have the discussions we'll talk
about them later that are arising as a
result uh who are you protecting you you
lials out there are you only protecting
one side or are you protecting the other
side it's getting to be a very
interesting debate for sure now so
definitely assassination attempts really
bring out a yes um this was just also a
quick uh article on the slov Slovakian
prime minister who opposed the World
Health Organization pandemic treaty shot
in an assassination attempt that was a
while ago so this assassination attempt
which occurred as he was leaving a
government meeting comes only a few days
after Slovakia announced that it would
not support the who pending pandemic
agreement that's another interesting one
you know where you have this world
government push in a particular
direction but these people come out
Heroes at the end of the process and
they Galvanize the political world into
a particular
mindset and you know the health issue
was also a very important point in the
election and who was right and who was
wrong and who pushed it to the point of
coercion Etc that's all part of the
debate at the moment One World
Government against your nationalistic
orientation it's another divide that's
taking place in the world and that also
brings religion always in it because you
always have the the um One World type of
view will be the more secularised View
and the another one is the Christian um
view the like this if you want to get
rid of the globalist and all of that
it's always the Christian side putting
personal freedom and autonomy against
what a greater body wants in this
particular case they mention sorus as
the one who is the billionaire globalist
who is funding the left ideology and
then you have Elon Musk who is also a
billionaire and he's talking on the
other side of the divide and you know
people are so riled up that they
actually begin to hate
certain people like sorus for example
and the question is then why are they
allowed to operate with so much Freedom
why are they allowed to give their funds
to projects like flooding the borders
for
example why why is this all
permitted it should be able to be
controlled quite simply right but it's
never controlled and it's always those
people out there that are causing the
problem it's like front
organizations who are the real Puppet
Masters behind the scenes real hard to
follow the the blame I appreciate how
you mentioned that that division that
that is polarizing people and that was
the thing that worried me most about
what was happening during the pandemic
it wasn't whether you get a vaccine or
not to me it was like I was so concerned
about
how are God's people treating each other
during that time are we extending Grace
and M is our character going to be worse
by the time this is over or is it going
to be better exactly and that was a big
issue you saw the way people kind of
divided during that whole situation and
I mean it was like we're going to fight
over this like you know in in a way that
it I it really Drew lines in some
Churches and things but I think it will
also the same will happen with M this
election a lot of people if you don't if
you're not an observer and you're going
to be sucked into one of the two sides
MH you're going to make a it's going to
get messy and people will like they
won't like you if you don't make a
choice for one of for sure you you're in
the crosshairs exactly so this is just
some videos on what happened after the
assassination Temp and what were some of
the comments that was made fight fight
fight fight fight
fight we got Time come on hey we are in
the fight for the soul of our nation we
are in a fight for our kids and our
grandkids a fight that we can never
imagine I believe wholeheartedly Donald
Trump and Butler County's JD Vance are
the last chance to save our country
politically I'm afraid if we lose this
one it's going to take a civil war to
save the country and it will be saved
it's the greatest experiment in the
history of mankind and if we come down
to a civil war I'm glad we got people
like schmidi and the bikers for Trump on
our side if you don't vote we're not
going to win the election if you do vote
we're going to win in a landslide too
big to rig we're going to win in a
landslide but Christians you know you'll
go to church every
Sunday and Pastor Paula White and all of
the people people I understand they're
doing lock boxes in churches where
people don't even have to go to vote
they can now vote in church and if you
do that we're going to win by numbers
that nobody's ever seen before you know
you have tremendous power but you just
don't know that but you have to use that
power Christians are a group that's
known not to vote very much you have to
go out at least this election just give
us in get us into that beautiful white
house vote for your congressmen and
women vote for your Senators we will
change this country for the better this
country will be great again like never
before so Mark Zuckerberg calls me first
of all he called me a few times he
called me after the event and he said
that was really amazing it was very
brave and you know and he actually
announced he's not going to support a
Democrat because he can't because he
respected me for what I did that day I
think what I did maybe was a norm to me
it was a normal response but I was
called by Mark Zuckerberg yesterday the
day before on this same subject and he
actually apologized he said they made a
mistake etc etc and they're correcting
the mistake uh Google nobody call from
Google nice pause I mean what he's doing
there I mean just putting the ballot
boxes in the churches is too close to
blending church and state right off the
bat yes I mean there is so many things
going on here that that you are seeing
the writing on the wall yeah now a few
years ago if you said that there would
be Christian legislation pass in this
country you were regarded as on the
border of insanity right can never
happen in this country tin hat
conspiracy theorist conspiracy and it's
the greatest conspiracy story in the
Bible but it's happening MH whether
contrived or not is irrelevant the fact
of the matter is Bible prophecy will be
fulfilled because God cannot be wrong
that's right because history has proved
that prophecy gets fulfilled whether we
like it or not you can go and build a
statue of solid gold from head to toe to
say Babylon will never
fall but it will fall that's right
that's right exactly that's right
interesting and and you know every time
that that that you have examples in the
Bible of this um sort of world dominance
right yes there's worship attached to
that always you need to worship and
every time that worship is forced God
has to step in there's a lot of people
on the internet that that I think that
this particular message and and and
seeing that where it's going to play out
in this worship Arena there's a lot of
people that are linking the mark of the
beast to some sort of you know chip
you're going to take and this and that
and it's all just kind of taking your
focus off of what's going on something
that's happening on over there in the
Middle East it's kind of like not
focusing necessarily on you know this
this is these ideologies that are Waring
against each other like Daniel 11 I TR
truly do believe King of the North King
of the South two mindsets that are
fighting against each other and and um
you know the religious
world will dominate because that's what
the Bible says and then it will force
that worship and if you want to
Galvanize a people then the rhetoric has
to get uh more and more
aggressive so if you want to push people
into their camp and keep them there then
just increase the negative rhetoric on
the other side mhm and we'll see that in
the next one yeah this video will surely
show that I'd like to punch him in the
face I said if we were in high school
had take him behind the gym and beat the
hell out of him punch some people in the
face when was the last time an actor
assassinated a president they're still
going to have to go out and put a bullet
in Donald Trump and that's a
fact look as his character is stabbed to
death where is John wil's Booth when you
need him this way
that's it right there pull it up I have
thought an awful lot about blowing up
the White House I will go and take Trump
out tonight I'm usually really fast to
talk wow I don't know if I have
words it's you know I I think I
mentioned this yesterday when we were
talking is uh you know these are the the
Democrats right the the people on the
left of the spectrum the ones that don't
that want more gun reform more gun
control they don't want they don't want
guns but there's a whole lot of violent
language in those comments I mean we
could have been watching a WWF episode
right here now what will this do just
psychologically what will it do to the
mindset of those that support the agenda
mhm of the right yeah won't it Galvanize
it absolutely won't it make them close
ranks yeah it's not going to show their
Christianity they're going to take the
approach of fighting fire with fire
instead of turning the other cheek yes
exactly you see so it's so
much riling up mhm that either way the
election goes it can be a problem you've
we've listened to the how many people
now talking about a civil war mhm yeah
that was interesting that he kind of
made that threat that came out I mean
that almost felt like it was a threat
what's it going to take not the first
one it's going to take it w and they've
ained I mean even from from the Heritage
Foundation that it could be a bloodless
Revolution if Trump wins but if the
other side wins it could be a bloody
Revolution I come full circle in this
response and just want to encourage you
with some substance that we are in the
process of the second American
Revolution which will remain bloodless
if the left allows it to be I mean we
live in Tennessee here and I need to
move further away both sides are saying
that so we're living in a very
interesting time now the Olympic uh
events in France are playing right into
this now France is such a fascinating
country you know you had the French
Revolution and I believe that Revelation
chapter 11 talks about that tremendous
mind shift in ideology where you had the
the middle-ages mindset of the church
rules absolutely to the mind mind ET of
the church has no say whatsoever do what
thou Wilt is the whole of the law uh
Liberty Liberty to do what thou
wilh and that has basically been the
mindset since the French
Revolution I I think it's a very clever
deploy if you're thinking about demonic
Puppet Masters behind the scene because
the Bible says it's a philosophy that
comes from the bottomless pit and this
philosophy has taken over the world
before we had
monarchies after you had
democracies now even Aristotle already
said the final step before tyranny is
democracy because eventually it will
become so bad and uh the rule of law
will just disappear because everybody
wants to be without the rule of law mhm
that eventually it becomes so chaotic
that the only solution is tyranny you
desire somebody to make some sort of Ral
decision you need a strong man now who's
that strong man going to be what is that
picture that they showed of Donald Trump
with his fist in the air what does that
show a weak man or a strong man strong
man yeah they said there was a
transformation in this man I mean
there's they're using all the language
of like you know he's like reborn I mean
you know just in a movie making there's
there's you know
um that guy Joseph Campbell that wrote a
hero without or a hero Thousand Faces
hero of hero's journey a man of journe
man with thousand faces and it follows
this cycle basically you can fit every
single story into this cycle and it's
pretty wild I've seen people do this
with cartoons with Star Wars with you
name it it follows the cycle the only
one that fits outside of that cycle that
they don't know what to do with this
Jesus he does not fit that model and so
you know this kind of thing right here
is following in that cycle it's
interesting all right if you if you look
at this whole campaign and the rhetoric
that is associated with the campaign and
these people are proclaimed Christians I
mean whether it's the Biden Camp they
are ston Christian Catholics for example
Biden or even Pelosi that was speaker
for a long time and the other side is
also claiming to be strong Christian do
you see true Christian sentiments coming
out or do you see something else true
Christianity really is a you know
humbleness
meekness you know all the fruits of the
spirit right seeking after righteousness
I mean think of all those character
traits that that guy that came out even
Trump fight fight fight that's not the
true sentiment Jesus is going to the
Cross Peter steps up no we're going to
take these guys out we're going to fight
right takes the guy's ear off Jesus
walks around I mean I would I can't wait
to see that scene Jesus picking up the
ear walking back over on the man and
putting it back on being like guys this
is not how I want it it's amazing that
they still took him after that that was
the religious mindset of the day that he
grew up with as a Jew you know it was
like we need to get rid of the Romans
they in our faces we got to rebel
against these guys they had zealots that
were killing them and they'd get in
trouble and be crucified over it I mean
their mindset was anti-roman and we'll
go to violence to accomplish that in
Jesus's day they had this same thing and
it's interesting that an ear played such
a prominent role yeah can an ear Chang
the course of history it's certainly
yeah yeah not the tongue he didn't cut
out his tongue all right so here it was
an event that took place in the United
States of America and now we moved to
France and and you had this this
uh activity that was going on there that
was supposedly mocking the Last Supper
although they say it wasn't it was the
Olympic gods that they were mocking but
nevertheless did that event galvanized
Christianity in the entire world what
happened in France just after that they
came together in their
thousands on the side of Christianity
and Jesus M they had rallies as a
consequence it is a galvanizing time
when when Christians are saying we're
being bullied we we've been bullied by
Islam we're being bullied Now by
secularism enough is enough what do you
do when you get power under those
conditions you legislate that's right
you're going to make it happen so that
people don't put you back in that
situation yeah all right right let's
move a little bit further and let's
become defiant against this separation
of church and state so the Louisiana
governor he ordered that the Ten
Commandments be displayed in the
schools and that the kids that were
opposed to it or the parents of the kids
should tell their kids just don't look
at it but we're not taking it away it's
staying there then the the left said we
will take you to court and he says I
welcome it I wanted to go all the way to
the Supreme
Court now if we look at the con at the
composition of the Supreme
Court are they going to be on the side
of the separation of church and state or
will they redefine that
boundary if you look at the
majority on the Supreme Court that will
give you an indication yes exactly what
is the majority it's a Roman Catholic
majority and who put that majority in
place wasn't it Donald
Trump I've also heard that a lot of the
generals of our armies um the generals
are all Catholic a large portion of them
yes so I mean you think if you got the
dominoes or the chest pieces in the
right positions uh we're we're set up
here interesting about your photo here
um that says Declaration of Independence
and it looks like the 10 commandments I
mean who nobody makes a document with
two circles on the top and there's
another one on the other side that says
United States Constitution and it's also
like something written in stone I mean
there's there's a lot of of of church
and not only there but also the French
Revolution they brought out the
Declaration of Human Rights and that was
also in the form of the Ten Commandments
interesting but above it they had the
Fran hat which was the Hat of the sun
god Mitra that's the yeah and then then
you had the allseeing eye which which is
the main emblem of the Jesuits MH and
there's no doubt that the French
Revolution was led by the Jesuits we all
know that Vol was a Jesuit and many of
the role players were Jesuits Napoleon
was connected somehow and this all
happened in the time period when the
papacy received a mortal wound it had
lost its power it had no more power to
legislate what if you push it to the
opposite extreme and you say all right
let's d ulate everything and let's lead
the world to the chaos that we have now
then we'll swing the pendulum back they
beg for and they beg for the control of
the church over the state isn't that
where we're heading mhm so is it a form
of hielan dialectic creating opposites
so that you can create a synthesis in
the end absolutely now Jamie Rasin is
the guy who was in charge of the uh
impeachment of Donald Trump well last
night I was most worried um about the
Supreme Court's prospective imminent
abdication of its very clear duty to
disqualify Donald Trump from the ballot
under section three of the 14th
Amendment and what that might mean if
their decision says that it's really up
to Congress on January 5th or January
6th
20125 um to disqualify him at the
counting of the Electoral College votes
which really could lead to something
akin to Civil War if that's if that's
what the suggestion is which is what I
think I heard so what he's saying here
is if he is elected we're going to
charge him with Insurrection under the
14th Amendment section three and
disqualify him before he is officially
sworn in as president of the United
States so they will overturn the the
vote
he is so serious about this now remember
this is the way these people have been
working they had they just say it and
because they have the media it just
becomes that then they just replaced now
remember Harris was um she was
incompetent she was a joke everybody in
the media knew that everybody said that
in fact the stories were just a week
before
she can't keep her staff she is so hated
she's a monster in the office and a week
later after hearing that for three years
a week later the new reality is that
it's kamelot like Camelot that she's
going to bring back the JFK years
because she's so beloved and so smart
and so
unifying so when they say things they
just expect everyone to believe it and
the sad thing is about 30% of the
population believes it what do you think
of K
Harris uh I think she is a politician
yeah and uh she's interested in the
accumulation of power and control do you
think she believes in
anything uh I think she believes in
government like most marxists yes I
think she is a Marxist do you think that
she can
win absolutely she can win this is this
is going to be a great
test of the power of the
media to take
someone who formerly was
universally disliked and transformed
them into a god-like figure and they
will use everything that they have to
try to do that the question is are the
American people smart enough to see
through it well the bottom line of that
one
is even if the left
wins what is the seed that has just been
planted if you want to save the nation
if you want to save the world and
they're saying if you want to save it
from World War II mhm then the only
solution is to take the power back and
that's why they're talking about
Revolution that's why they're talking
about Civil War so either way whether
the left wins in this election or
whether the right wins it's going to be
a very fascinating time could it lead to
a time of
trouble such as we have never seen
before yeah could it lead to a little
time of trouble and eventually then
because of religious legislation mhm
lead to a great time of trouble mhm is
the table late can it happen you right
it takes as a spark right yeah MH it
really makes you wonder you know I I
look over the history of the world and
there's been some bad times that our
world has endured and if Jesus's words
are right there's going to be a time
that no other people have ever
experienced this I think it's going to
get pretty bad all right but there's
another there's another side to the
story just's look at this slide over
here Trump greets Netanyahu at Mar Lago
and says World War I
could happen if Harris
wins so this is no longer speculation
that the people are talking about these
issues this is a reality we'll see how
it goes but if all works out if we win
it will be very simple it's all going to
work out and very quickly Trump said if
we don't you're going to end up with
major wars in the Middle East and maybe
a third world war what
if it becomes a
peacemaker and suddenly Russia lays down
its arms Ukraine gets silent the Middle
East is calmed down and the world shouts
peace peace at last what does the Bible
say happens then then sudden destruction
comes upon a woman as travail Upon A or
travail upon a woman so all sides could
actually fulfill biblical prophecy right
y both sides and and interesting also
like you mentioned before that the media
is playing a big role mhm both sides is
acknowledging it exactly and both sides
are have the rhetoric right so it's very
interesting to watch Dr Carson on there
talking about how the media is placing
such a role in Kamala and no doubt it is
but it's also playing a role for Trump
you know it's both sides are putting out
their own rhetoric and accusing the
other one of doing the thing that
they're doing so they if you look at
this there's no peace talks now it's
only civil war and War and War yeah
that's that's a fascinating element that
but like yeah but like you mentioned
what if there's a peacemaker in all of
this a shift yes interesting but even
like the idea that they're going to make
um you know Cala like a Godlike figure
you know that was kind of fascinating
too because I don't know it's like they
don't they don't they don't care about
God right but didn't you also mention
earlier that there was a lot of this
nuances in the speech that made him a
Godlike figures only got almost got two
Gods against each other yeah interesting
so now let's put the Islamic issue into
into the fry and say all right now we
have all of these internal issues with
the the left policies which are riling
up Christians let's add the Islamic
issue in there and we have the riots in
in Britain and what happened in Germany
Germany has shut down one of the
country's largest and oldest mosques and
ordered a ban on the Nationwide Shia
Muslim organization that runs it for
religious
extremism dozens of police raided
hamburg's Blue Mosque on Wednesday
morning as well as 53 other properties
across Germany in one of the most
significant crackdowns on political
islamism in the country in
years the interior Ministry said it was
formerly Banning the Islamic Center of
Hamburg and its Affiliated organizations
for preaching total Arian rule
aggressive anti-Semitism and support for
the terror group
hisbah three other mosques in Berlin
Frankfurt and Munich have also been
raided and
closed so we're having a
backlash what the Christian world let's
call it that for lack of a better term
is saying enough we want to go back to
values of Christianity and like we said
in our previous discussion even if
you're an atheist
they're saying we want those cultural
norms to rule over us and not these
other Norms to rule over us and the
Battleground for the implementation of
the mark of the beast is the Christian
world the rest will follow for economic
reasons or whatever other reason secular
reason there might be but the
Battleground for the mind is the
Christian
world yeah and and then you've got the
people that are not actually open
Christian like Elon Musk they also got a
lot to say about all of this so why is
Elon Musk clashing with the UK
government over far right riots so on
Sunday musk tweeted that Civil War is
inevitable in the UK in response to a
post claiming that open borders and
migration had led to the protests in one
response to a post that claimed that an
armed Muslim Patrol group had attacked
civilians and a News Network crew musk
directly tweeted at Prime Minister strus
asking why aren't all communities
protected why are you
selectively as the left protecting some
and not others why are you not
pro-christian but you're acting as
though you're
proslim why are you allowing these
things to happen and look what happened
to those little children and all of
these emotional things that are
happening in the world today
irrespective of how they happened and
why they happened they are galvanizing
the Christian world into saying so far
and no further that's interesting to
hear about the the the the wars around
the world right in the horses right that
are coming isn't the red horse the war
the black horse the death the pale hor
is kind of a mixture of all these right
and and in the order of the the horse is
coming does it mention the red being the
first one the red the red horse is the
one that has the martydom as its symbol
yes the White Horse the white hor is the
first one the White Horse is the first
one so so does that kind of tie into um
there's like War then you have
pestilence after the war then you have
kind of this mixture of all three and
then the obviously Jesus right and the
death is the the result of the wars and
the the death of the of the truth as a
result of the blending of paganism with
with uh with the
truth what's fascinating here is that
Elon Musk tweeted and he's not a very
strong professed Christian unless there
is more bravery to stand up for what is
fair and right Christianity will perish
um yeah go ahead cuz I know what you're
going to mention his profile picture his
profile picture I've seen that before
he's wearing that that the yeah it's
wearing B like satanic outfit making a
comment about Christianity is weird cath
is this interesting or is that not we
had a discussion about secret societies
let's not get all yeah you know Twitter
and bisted and involved in all of that
but if you put it all together it's like
we're living in a in an enatic circus
yeah it's a WWF it is I thought he was
Catholic because he seems like he
recently met with a pope with like five
of his kids or something he met with him
but that doesn't make him Catholic no I
I know but I just I thought he was
because he's not very outspoken about
his Christianity so yeah this is again
pushing for standing up for your
Christianity and I believe we should
stand up but not with fists that's right
and this was also pushing towards stuff
like that so what do you how did you
change it I guess I'll cut right to it
if you can fix El Salvador what are the
lessons for the rest of us what did you
do first we're literally the murder
capital of the world yes and we turn it
into the safest country in the Western
Hemisphere we're safer than any other
country in the western hemisphere which
is you know it was if I if I would have
said that five years ago they would say
that I was crazy right so you did that
in just a couple years yes we did that
in basically in three
years so what just bottom line it for us
what's the
formula well I can tell you the official
formula and the and the real formula
okay so the official formula is that we
did a plan I mean we did a plan it's not
that when I say official I'm not mean
it's a lie it's just you know the the
official one we did a a a a plan that
was comprised of faces yeah we we we
roll up the faces and then and then we
we we went after them okay so that's the
official that's the official yes that's
the official what what's what's the real
it's a miracle it's a miracle yeah it's
a miracle I love that what do you mean
yeah it's a miracle you know uh and uh I
I basically said well we I mean it's we
we we are we're looking into an
impossible impossible mission here so we
pray and uh and we and
we you prayed in the meeting yes yes of
course several times yeah what did you
pray for to wisdom to to win the war
to have I thought at the time that we
will have civilian casualties so we we
said we pray that the civilian
casualties will be as low as
possible and we didn't have any CI
civilian
casualties and was everyone in the
meeting comfortable with that yes yes
they every all my security cabinet are
believers they all believe in God we're
we're a secular country of course but we
all believe in God so you almost you
almost think this is the power of the
media right here running around showing
you what's the solution for all this yes
what is the solution that gets put out
and people you know Christianity this
gets passed around and people are going
to be like yeah yeah yeah yeah don't
they long for the solution let bring
Christianity into it and and that's the
crazy thing that's going to happen right
now is because we want people to come to
the gospel we want the world to respond
to God now can you imagine when it
finally happens and everybody says this
is the way this is the way of Peace this
is what we've been looking for and one
little obstinate group says excuse me
there's an error here we're following
the Commandments of men and not the
Commandments of God how popular are you
going to be yeah not you're not going to
be popular not at all so because of 99%
that it looks good because who doesn't
want peace who doesn't want um your
country to flourish and not be the
murder capital of the world mhm but like
you just mentioned that's only 99% of
the the story because there's 1% poison
in there and that little group is going
to be standing out like a sore thumb mhm
yeah you mix into that um natural
disasters that are completely like
getting you
know blown out of proportion if if you
would Satan's up in his Laboratories
like causing all these things to happen
right and and then it's like the acts of
God are happening because this little
group over here are not they're not
playing ball correctly yes let's have a
look at the next one okay so don't know
if anybody knows but Steve Bannon he
used to be in the government of trump
and then he went to jail recently for
his unwillingness to appear before the I
think the committee very deep questions
so I think we're heading towards a
constitutional crisis this country's
never had before yeah and uh and that's
one of the reasons I think I'm going to
prison they want to send me to prison in
July to make sure that the I think some
of the strongest or more more aggressive
of President Trump's president Trump's
Advocates are are taken off the uh are
taking off the playing field I think
that's right at some point it you just
have to say no no um last question so
you you've got four months you're facing
what do you plan to do with that time
like what are you going to read what are
you going to spend your time doing in
well I re I you know I I have a pretty
strict regimen as is so I'll continue on
I I do a lot of uh spiritual exercises
following uh St Ignatius loyol or you
know different uh spiritual excise that
come out of the Catholic church although
I'm a uh I'm a uh I I would actually say
if you look at our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ I would call myself a
pre-christian I I wouldn't want to
insult His Name by saying I'm a
Christian given the the the very tough
and high high standard that this is
where extremism is coming from your
government has turned against you not
our country the government a this
illegitimate regime has taken over the
apparatus of the United States
government and is enforcing dictatorial
power and we have to stand up for it
just like the Revolutionary generation
stood up to the dictatorial power of the
crown uh in the in people like the
British East India Company what they
hate most is Christianity for sure well
you're a brave and magnanimous man um
and so God bless you good
luck Tucker thanks look forward to
seeing you other
side thank you Steve I almost want to
say I rest my
case right because from the beginning I
believe that the Puppet Masters that
have been used by a greater Puppet
Master than them even are the
Jesuits I believe that the Jesuits were
behind the French Revolution and the
whole liberalization of humanity I
believe that the Jesuits are behind the
reunification and moving back to
absolute papal
Authority and that the power should be
given back to the Beast and I think
these government officials have just
confirmed that suspicion call it
conspiracy if you
want yeah when he says he's following
osus Lola who is a Jesuit he was the
founder he was the founder of the Jesuit
and these spiritual
exercises are hypnotic yeah they are the
ones that lead to an experiential
religion which is not based on faith
right but based on exercise yeah I mean
he could have said anything and he chose
to say that of all things it's crazy and
you remember I don't know if you were on
some of the shows that James uh we had
on and he was talking about how a lot of
these dictators throughout history they
were like look we wanted to study how to
do this and we studied the best model
there was the Catholic
church I think if there's any question
yeah the the the evidence is here let
people decide for themselves mhm real or
unreal is not not the point outcome what
is going to be the outcome we're going
to see the implementation of the mark of
the peace we're going to see the power
by the 10 horns given unto the Beast
we're going to see a attack on God's
people as a
consequence removing the final
opposition to the government that the
Devil Himself has set up on this planet
he wants to remove any opposition and
God's answer will be the plagues but
before that there's a loud cry and I
want to be part of it I don't know about
you guys amen amen amen it's it's
amazing to because God is very clear in
the book of Acts it says that he pours
out his Spirit on those who obey him yes
right and I remember studying one day
and and something kind of clicked I was
looking in the Book of Joel chapter 2
and it talks about all the the people
that God's spirit falls on remember it
says your sons and your daughters your
men's servants your maid servants it's
like listing these groups of people and
then you go to the Sabbath commandment
mhm and do you know the list of those
people is almost the same beautiful your
sons and your daughter your man servants
your maid servants it's God saying I
pour out my spirit on those who obey me
those who worship me in spirit and in
truth and the Sabbath is part of that I
mean anybody who is within thy Gates
right that's why it's important to
practice that now to look into that you
know I hope anybody out there that's
watching if you have not dived into
these kind of topics I pray that you're
probably familiar if you're watching
this on uh what's up Prof you're
familiar with their Ministry but um
maybe perhaps you haven't looked into
the Sabbath issue maybe you haven't
looked into Endtime prophecy events um
tell us where we can learn more about
that if somebody doesn't know where to
start where would you tell them to start
Martin where would you start well I
think a good place can be you can go to
our website clashof minds.com our
YouTube channel is a clash of Minds The
whatsa Prof series is on there they we
recently started a new series where what
is truth with Walter's son and my cousin
it's a well there's some interesting
things coming in that one as well yeah
and I think we are
also there's a lot of planning um of
getting tools into people's hands with
an app and some Bible study material and
we've also recently well pretty soon
we'll have a um a Evangelical school
that we'll be running two or three times
a year so go to our website and watch
out for that I love it Keith where can
uh they learn more about Bible
topics uh well if you're interested in
Bible topics we have a school as well
it's a bible school that we've partnered
with another organization on it's uh you
can reach it at
ls. school it's just straight Bible
studies and teaching you can ask
questions on there and and just go
through the Bible and study it and
discover what the truth of the word is
thank you guys so much for joining us
for this awesome discussion um I'm going
to have a lot to chew on and I'm sure
I'm going to be laying my head down
tonight just thinking about some of
these clips that we just watched that
are completely crazy but you know I I I
really am glad that God has told us
what's going to happen before because I
think that we know how this is going to
play out when you study it and you you
understand that's what Thessalonians
talked about we brought that up you know
when they say peace and safety and
sudden destruction comes upon them right
it's says but you are not in darkness
right that that day should overtake you
as a thief we are all children of the
light we're Children of the day
therefore let us not sleep but put on
the breastplate and the helmet of
salvation and um our Salvation is coming
look up look up and I want to make an
appeal to God's people to unite on what
we know is truth let's stop arguing and
fighting about non-essentials we're
right at the borders of Canaan
let's unite on the issues that are
important in this time amen good call
good call thank you guys for coming on
thank you guys for joining us please
like this video share it with somebody
that you know would get a blessing from
this if you haven't subscribed to our
ministry or their Ministry clash of the
minds please go to these YouTube
channels and a simple way that you can
help us out is just give the video a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel it's
like one little click that's a great way
to to help us get higher up in algorithm
but we're going to ask you for something
even more special than this I believe
that we're coming into a very dangerous
time and place in the world and we need
your prayers please pray that these
Ministries can actually continue forward
to continue to put out messages like
this because we've experienced a few
months back them taking the plug out of
the wall with um with um being able to
take our content down offline I'm sure
you guys have experience that as well so
we are on borrowed time pray for us if
you want to support so we can get these
things out there faster please join up
with us and partner with us so that we
can ready as many people to see Jesus
coming in the clouds we love you guys
thank you for watching we'll see you
next week
[Music]
l